well we were behind each other in  line at the grocery store and  it was silly but i dropped a can of peas  and he bent over to pick them up for me  and that's where it started what can i  say  it was love at first sight uh we've been  together ever since  well yes she always  has had her own way of doing things  okay i see what's going on here  honey you don't approve of our  engagement no they're not like that  i'm sorry sweetheart yes they are like  that look at the faces  there's no point in trying to reason  with folks  who can't appreciate the differences in  others you should be ashamed of  yourselves  [Music]  honey wait  [Music]  i cannot believe that you would bring a  colored man into our house  [Music]  he's gone now  you